[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que productrice carol parlait ce
qu'elle veut de moi qu'est ce qu'il ya
en fait un problème là la fibre fonction
de malte fait que tous mes magnéto sont
pas encore arrivés eh ben tu te bats
mais je m'en vais mais je reste je sais
pas s'ils ont dans l'autre peut-être on
peut commencer presti s'ils restent ici
reste ici moins cher soit juste il ya
quelqu'un dans public qui a gagné à mme
les cherry qui a gagné la tablette et
cette personne c'est le numéro 28
manu et la personne et la mairie gratuit
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien de la tablette et on a le
gagnant également twitter est ce qu'on a
les images de cédric 6 r oui ou non ou
merde un sens je rentre chez moi et
balesi pas fait bafé leur n'allait ni à
les jeter s'il se plaît tétouan julie et
mais nous les trois premiers matches
mais quand même fatiguée elle arrête pas
de me parler je sais pas ce qu n'ai rien
compris du courage et merci
d'accord on verra justement qui gagnera
le tarn abattoirs chaleur il ya un gros
suspense avec avec ça ou dernier virage
[Rires]
dans le temps but alors ça va alors pour
commencer je vais parler donner parce
que kelis et l'ancien dj tôt convertis
comme spécialiste média maintenant mais
elle peut vous citez n'importe quelle
émission télédiffusée après 14 heures à
11 heures elle dort donc c'est compliqué
alors qu'elle est naturelle et spontanée
alors ça donne des séquences que je vais
désormais désignés comme des vélos
vélite la v de v dit c'est quoi ça peut
être une phrase peut être une réaction
que seul kevin une vidéo mais voilà ça
peut être ça fait une réaction ou une
phrase que seul toi tu peux avoir kelly
donc pour le ward de la meilleure veine
d'eau bénite
les nommés sont
élimine au belize qui a du mal à cacher
qu'elle déteste qu'on lui donne un
surnom s'il ya des tas de gens choqués
comme un gosse il ya eu des tas de gens
du gué oui oui moyens toujours pas
choquer donc l'usiné quand même c'est
mon pays rappelle deschamps qui voulait
parler oui
[Musique]
iv novelli qui soudain se transforme en
spécialiste média pour défoncer benjamin
castaldi c'est vrai que ça plutôt bien
produit sur la question il ya des
questions très difficiles et des
surfaces et donc on peut jouer avec lui
donc très bien et surtout c'est un
format français créé voilà effectivement
je mets cette voie j'approuve herman si
je peux préciser c'est pas jeu français
c'est un jeu argentin ouais ça ne tenait
pas ses fiches on se prononcent pas
[Musique]
je vivais de gagner qui est de bon
conseil pour convaincre photos ou de
revenir avec gilles verdez collet passé
koné fatoumata des fans est revenu il
faut qu'il apprenne à l'envers ah oui
[Rires]
je crois je prends la deuxième le
benfica style casta oui c'est cassano
les places pour ces journées ou de fatou
alors je pense avoir une vraie évolution
c'est à dire lundi ça aurait des choses
à vous dire lundi mais aujourd'hui non
c'est pas un truc c'est le week-end on
se voit ce soir
regardez pas balances ton post après il
va nous faire une hollande
le rendez vous est à ce qu elle a redit
ce après de tpm peu après les faits et
alors 30 ça nous laisse le temps de
regarder a été entendu et a lancé rendez
vous avenue emile et fatou est ce que tu
attends devient un mot jusqu'à la fin de
l'effet c'est quoi veut voir débat sur
millage voulait dit ça me passionne
arrive à huy suisse fipa d'or après on
se voit d'accord vous l'avez dit repris
btp alors elle qu'à donner leur nom
c'est quoi pourquoi pas avant que les
choix à faire avant
alors j'ai d'ailleurs je ne sais pas bon
mais elle possède qui vous demande à
vous voir oui elle m'a envoyé un message
la nuit dernière sur quoi tu vas rire je
te quitte moi la raison
on n'est pas il faudrait en fait il
faudrait qu'on se voit et c'est je crois
que c'est un peu difficile pour elle les
messages que les gens c'est ce que vous
disais l'autre jour qu'il a fait chaud
au coeur c'est vrai l'émulateur que les
gens on voit c'est un avouant facile
donc elle a envie d'en parler dont elle
a très bien bon je pense que ça va ça va
se résorber cette affaire on espère
lundi on aura des nouvelles on sait que
comme ça tout le week end
bon bah écoute et on espère que ça va
bien se passer on espère alors on va
être honnête dans touche pas à mon poste
il ya plus de vannes que de scouts
médias ce qu'a d'ailleurs fois que
j'entends nos scoops ici j'étais coiffé
comme valérie benaïm attend mais en vain
et si on se régale franchement on se
régale vous a sélectionné trois vannes
vous aime bien laquelle vous préférez
c'est parti
jean michel maire qui nous balance toute
la vérité sur l'ancienne vie de valérie
bénaïm alias valoches la galoche
enseigne un livre à lire livre mais
quant à l'aide en ligne
combien elle tombe plus vite les slips
que les pages je connais par coeur les
zizis qu'elle a vu de près ou de loin
une bonne mémoire
[Rires]
benjamin castaldi spécialiste en mariage
mais aussi en histoire de france qu'on
retour au xvème siècle au xvème siècle
ces problèmes sont 15e siècle avait une
parfaite égalité dans le peuple entre
les hommes
[Rires]
cyril hanouna impatient d'aller dans la
boîte de nuit préférée de matthieu
delormeau ya une boîte que j'adore là
bas et tout promet ses besoins by the
fire qui étouffe le boys and fire est
non c'est pas que gay friendly
le boys and fire oui c'est une boîte et
là bas j'en fais pas la cup
[Rires]
le byron parker qu'elle va nous
préférait alors moi je la boîte c'est
pas ma voix la boîte existe le boys and
fire abeilles vous attendent toujours
tenues kouyias vaille à maxime qui dit
qu'ils étaient il est temps il n'est pas
moi qui bosse obama qu'est ce qui t'a
maxime d'écouté des partis au bundle
d'ailleurs on l'a plus jamais revu leur
ai pas trouvés sont payés avec
l'angleterre comme il adore la bannière
sera de retour demain notre maxime
allais alors 5,5 êtes un modèle pour
tous ceux qui veulent devenir animateur
télé parce que quand on vous regarde
c'est une leçon d'animation on apprend à
jeter des balles de ping pong des
saladiers on apprend ce verset de la
somme ou sur la tête et surtout on
apprend à faire la promotion des
programmes juste après l'émission
et ça c'est mon moment préféré c'est du
grand art à la toute fin de l'émission
le générique part et vous commencez à
faire la promo ce qui a juste après
c'est important
le nommé pour le meilleur lancement de
prime et c'est important
ces rides hanouna qui ne sait pas du
tout ce qui lie à ce soir sur ces 8
mais ce côté colorier traitants merci à
tous cyril hanouna qui est largement le
meilleur pour faire la promo d'une de
ses chroniqueuses et son prime on va se
retrouver bien sûr demain tout de suite
sur s'est vite je ne sais pas du tout ce
qu'il a fait je suis serein pour ses
bras ses valets les menacer les maisons
hantées
[Applaudissements]
et cyril hanouna qui sait donner envie
aux téléspectateurs de rester pour
l'émission diffusée juste après tpm p
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être parce que c'était je me
rappelle ce faire un numéro qui était
produit par bernard de la villardière
pour ça puisque j'adore
carole rousseau qui est une amie et qui
a cartonné d'ailleurs lié en sort et
c'est vrai quoi là une fois sur tf1 vous
êtes viré tout de suite
ah ouais c'est un pur l'ordre et non
mais aussi contre un nouvel emprunt si
vous avez vu ici au moins on a une
liberté
non non non non non pas du tout on l'a
vu hier alors alors suppléante à revenir
d'ailleurs souvent et benjamin castaldi
d'un mois pour hier qu'il fut critiqué
canal b si la fsh sur nrj 12
il aurait pas fait mouche il aurait fait
haggaï mundi ici on a une liberté
d'expression qui est incroyable je veux
dire ça on veut tous lançait alors là tu
veux ça sur tf1 il devrait alors ça sur
tf1 tu étais de hockey de la khl aucune
programmé joli corps aurait ensuite
aussi d'ailleurs dehors ont médicalisé
dit la vérité
oui parce que tu vas rentrer dedans à la
cuve en dix ans ferme ta gueule arrête
de paraître canal+ ce qui te paye ses
amis je dis la vérité de mai mais la
directrice est bonne et on a le droit
déjà des critiques vous allez rouler
dans mon critique plein de fois les
programmes de canal + 2 s'est vite de
ses stars mais un moment quand vous
dites canal+ qui est responsable des
césars ou paca n'a plus qu'à là on
parlait des césars ya je vous explique
et aux césars c'est une académie de 5000
personnes qui décident des films faits
pour ça n'est pas cadré vous n'arrêtez
pas de dire canal+ vous êtes bien
content d'aller voir canal+ après pour
aller demander des prod donc voila merci
et puis ça n'a rien à voir je pose la
distribution qui vont diffuser qui le
diffuse msss le dit c'est juste le
diffuser leurs messages de diffuseurs
québécois qui est bien pour tous et non
mais si cyril te dis ferme la gueule
ferme ta gueule c'est pour la leur et je
vous jure
et je vous avais prévenu
et qu'est la maison je vous jure que je
disais ça pour vous parce qu'après la
direction de carey plus à vous appeler
va vous dire mine de rien fais attention
voilà soit soit ça soit là soit tu sois
cool avec moi oui bien sûr parce qu on a
une liberté ton formidable moi j'en ai
fait des groupes mais ici on peut
défoncer les programmes personne ne nous
dit rien quand on tousse à l'institution
canal partout c'est compliqué alors
qu'un joueur du psg qui poussera
l'incendié même moi j'ai mon camion si
je critique mon camion mois la non mais
votre patron si vous le crétacé je
retire mon patron moi aussi bien sûr
mais si je vais aider un autre mec à
décharger un camion d'une autre société
je vais me faire défoncer bien sûr nous
avez vous imaginé sur tf1 un mec qui dit
oui mais enfin
non mais benjamin aussi un motif de
licenciement
bah on peut penser c'est bien on a fait
un petit débat comme les images
n'étaient pas arrivés j'arrive dans un
instant mon chéri tu as le ba ba de la
scène funk cn entendu il ya 4 qui sera
avec nous a tout de suite le petit
bounty
vous savez que chaque sommet je vous
montre les trois meilleures blagues de
la grosse rigolade précédentes vous
savez alors bon bien sûr les trois
blagues ne sont pas au niveau de celle
d'isabelle morini-bosc mais vous allez
devoir choisir entre les trois nommés
mohamed benyamna plus connu sous le nom
de google arrive à londres attend le mec
il est papa l'anglais tu crois il
descend en bas de chez lui à un mariage
de fou il croise une nana ce disque usé
moi c'est qui qui se marient jamais dû
dire non
le lendemain et des sens où tout le
monde pleure dans son quartier il croise
la dame et excusez moi qui ixic est mort
la table des rails dans claudie le
pauvre s'est marié hier francis ginibre
des chevaliers du fiel
ça se passe sur une plage banc d'essai
le mois d'août il fait très chaud
et là il ya un non voyant qui arrivent
il sort son sac sur un gros truc en
caoutchouc il sort un un gonfleur de
plage c'est avec le pied et commence à
gonfler et d'un seul coup
en fait il se rend pas compte mais c'est
pas un matelas pneumatique qui ont fermé
c'est une grosse poupée qui commence à
penser en vo lycée qui se lève qui
alignait qui lit mais monsieur l'année
arrêtez-vous je bosse à l'opr il ya ceux
qui jouent alors le noyage y aller je
comprends pas qu est ce qui se passe
mais s'il ne pouvait là que vous gonflez
elle ne revoyait il fait mais [ __ ]
mais j'ai baisé le zodiaque tous libres
[Rires]
et jean marie bigard avec le sniper qui
va venger son ami qui apprend qu'il est
cocu et dit vas-y toi la vallée là bas
la petite maison blanche a tous droit
c'est ma maison dit vas-y aligne tu
avoir la qualité quoi et qui lie et
galettes au dit [ __ ] j'ai l'impression
d'être chez toi est malade il monte à
l'étagé là il voit sa femme
bah voilà avec un mec sont en train de
s'embrasser goulûment
oui tu dis quoi avec un autre mais
tardive asie et aurait dit que seven de
mal tu vas mettre une balle dans la tête
à ma femme dans la vie de ces sentiers
et là le mec qui écoute si tu me donne
l'autorisation de tir et maintenant je
peux économiser une balle
[Rires]
pour moi pour moi la meilleure c'est
good hair aussi donc noël ouvert qui
sera avec nous demain dans la grosse
rigolade au doigt jean marie bigard qui
sera là yacco et ya titoff
il ya eu il ya de folie il ya tout le
monde a franchement demain il ya baffie
bien entendu il ya has du très très
lourd devant manger sans surprise c'est
que j'aimerais si vite et une blague de
qui vous verrez demain de mont-tramelan
benyamna à bout des rues sous le nom de
bouder bien se passer sur le terrain
c'est bouder quand il était petit on va
voir son papa il dit papa c'est quoi le
truc on l'a sur la tête son père lui dit
comme ça c'est la charia
quand on marche dans le désert c'est
bien contre le soleil comme ça on n'a
pas de l'insolation est l'acronyme est
pas promet une grande robe 10 as une
djellaba quand on est dans le désert tu
vas pas beaucoup sué avec ça n'est pas
pourquoi on a des chaussures blizzard ne
s'est pas d'exception nizar ça c'est des
babouches
quand tu marches dans le désert le sable
y rentre pas non plus très bien son père
mais papa puisque les si bien équipé
pour le désert qu'est ce qu'on fout
argenteuil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera demain les merci d'être aussi
nombreux à regarder cette émission
concédé contre d'autres choses et oui il
est temps de connaître celui ou celle
qui a le plus sacré ses collègues
derniers jours
qui sera le vingtième tard baba musique
de suspense et pas moi cette semaine
performer sur scène on a besoin de
remporter le trophée 26 fois d'affilée
après comme incidence 26 et le nombre
des missions que vous animez chaque
semaine est ce que vous avez peur d'un
concurrent éventuel en termes de tarbes
habitudes ou pas mathieu mathieu oui à
tout tu me fais peur
oui si c'est un bâtard
est ce que la france est prête pas ce
que je vais dire tout de suite oui le
même septième terme à ba2 l'histoire de
touche pas à mon poste
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya eu au niveau mais moi pour
moi mention spéciale ouais c'est pour
moi c'est beaucoup c'est très lente in
bon sens que ça qu'on la chute où vous
rendez hommage à la bouche de géraldine
maillet couper ma vous allez kiffer
regardez c'est pas ça le fait que j qui
alors vous êtes qui déjà est un
compliment bébé même et surtout comment
quand même loin devant moi j'ai marco ah
mais vous avez un [ __ ] laveur autour du
cou gilles franchement je ferai tout ce
que vous voudrez pour vous aider dans
ces gentils voilà donc on va voir s'il
aimait ou quitter paul eluard caissière
d'un poète aimait ou quitter barre toi
nous n'avons je vais la garder cette
fausse et les loups je peux je vais
garder cette photo match et dire qu'il
en reste rack de lanester
en fait ces virus il se transmet la même
façon que vous transmettez la grippe par
le contact les gouttelettes salivaires
dans internet et vous positionner comme
le bacille de la tuberculose
il ne vous connu par les crachats pas ça
c'est votre assistant toulon elle
soulagée plus en plus c'est dingue ça
c'est pas parce qu'elle a une tradition
avec j ouer notamment la manière
suivante vous coûte
[Applaudissements]